[Musique]
pour ses prochaines vacances le musée va
proposer des activités
de pour les 5 ans jusqu'aux plus de huit
ans m 10 12 ans il ya différentes
activités qui sont toujours en lien avec
nos collègues
marie c'était la résidence de chasse de
louis xiv on est en automne donc on va
faire des propositions autour de cire
des plats
[Musique]
pour les 6 12 ans va travailler
notamment autour de de la saison
l'automne on va travailler en expression
propre pour elle notamment autour des
saisons donc qu'en soit un garçon ou une
fille on va voir devenir une feuille un
arbre on aura aussi une composition
autour d'un atelier pratique mais vitale
donc cette fois ci on écoute vivaldi et
puis ensuite on est musicienne quitte à
mettre une trentaine d'instruments
visite à disposition les enfants et puis
pour les justement pour les plus petits
à partir de 5 ans on propose un nouveau
rendez vous c'est un rendez vous en
famille autour des contes
[Musique]
le fait de t'accueillir les enfants ça
répond quand même à une mission première
des musées c'est tout simplement
transmettre partager l'idée c'est
toujours qu'il ya un écho entre ce qu'on
fait et le lieu où on se trouve donc à
chaque fois on va découvrir ou un
tableau ou une partie des collections du
musée pour travailler ensuite en atelier
c'est tout simple il ya un petit
bulletin à remplir qui est disponible
sur notre site internet mais si c'est à
la dernière minute on prend son
téléphone on nous appelle on accepte
aussi les ateliers ne sont pas complets
des des inscriptions de dernière minute